all around Breton you will find this
tactile paving to help blind and
partially sighted people find the way
around and here's the clever part and
the part that almost everyone who is
fully sighted will never have noticed
there are different patterns for
different situations very few people see
nothing at all that's important to say
only about 3%
some people have light perception and
some people have a bit more vision some
people have a limited field of vision
some people have poor central vision but
good peripheral visions essentially
think of partially sighted people with
enough vision to be able to get around
safely and independently blind being
below that threshold dots in a grid like
this mean a dropped curb for crossing
the road if it's read earlier it's
supposed to be read then it's a crossing
with lights or something else to stop
traffic these designs of partially
sighted people - so bright contrasting
colors are a good idea there is a small
amount of tactile paving here uses a
marker to flag up where the crossing is
and then near the road it's for the full
length of the crossing so you can work
out where it is and it's important to
balance marking the crossing against not
using too much tactile paving because
someone with arthritis can find services
like this painful to cross navigating
around an unfamiliar area is always a
bit scary to be honest because obviously
the traditional visual clues landmarks
etc are there it helps a lot
if Clues are consistent so confusion can
certainly occur when that isn't the case
it's very very important that these
adaptations that are there to help us
are actually there to help us and are
actually there in the way that we expect
to see them but there are other patterns
to offset dots mean there's a train
platform ahead a big chasm you could
fall into laws in shapes mean a tram
platform something close to street level
that could run you over stripes across
the paths mean there's some steps ahead
or a couple of other things that could
trip you up stripes along the path mean
a safe route to follow and if there's a
path that's half of foot traffic and
half of bicycles what the direction of
the stripes tells you which side is
which
Dara's in London Councils outside of
London
seem to be moving more towards aesthetic
considerations ie they're changing the
color to darker gray so it blends in
more by definition if it blends in more
it's harder for partial sight of people
such as myself to actually see or
obviously in a more dire situation
people can find themselves in the road
not knowing they're in the road super
because those essential clues aren't
there and sure all this is tricky to get
right the design standards for how this
is laid down are literally a hundred
pages long but so the design standards
for everything about public
infrastructure having reliable rules
that everyone understands is important
when there are tons of metal speeding
past II thank you very much to the team
from the Royal National Institute of
blind people for all the help you can
check out their YouTube channel here and
yes I put a link to the full 100 page
design document in the description